we
the people of the united states in order
to form a more
perfect union
[Music]
um
welcome to this hillsdale college online
course called constitution
101 by constitution we of course mean
the greatest and longest living of all
the constitutions in history the
constitution the united states
we study that here because we're mindful
of the fact and always have been at
hillsdale
that we are citizens and we need our
freedom
in order to live well and do our work
especially the work of a college which
radically depends upon
freedom of every kind we teach the
constitution to every student here at
the college
and now we're going to help you learn
something about it
the other people who are teaching in
this are members of our politics faculty
i'm a member of that
faculty myself and among them all
they may have the most knowledge of the
meaning of the constitution
and the significance of the changes that
have gone on
around it and so it should be a
privilege for you to watch this and i
hope you enjoy it
and i hope you uh read
and continue learning about this for as
long as you live
and teach others too so much i'll
explain depends on that
there are a lot of details in this
course
details of how exactly things work and
why they work
details of different understandings than
the one that prevails here about those
things
and so that will involve us in some
complications
and it'll be helpful i think if we can
keep the kind of general points in mind
and i'm going to name some of those
today in my lecture
my first uh question i'll ask myself and
you
is what kind of thing are the declines
of independence in the constitution
turns out the answer to that is very
enriching
they're different documents uh there's
an argument
that they're opposed there's a powerful
argument
in the historical scholarship that the
declaration was meant to be a radical
document and the constitution was meant
to be
conservative and that
those people argue that the declaration
is about the rights of us all
and the constitution is really about
protecting the privileged
we we think that's nonsense around here
and even on its face it's nonsense for
one reason
uh at the time exact time the
declarative independence is from 1776
and the constitution's from 1787
so they're close together but never mind
there were all kinds of state
constitutions written
at the same time as the declaration of
independence
some of them signed by people who also
signed the declaration of independence
and they're all like the constitution
united states in
in their structure which i'm going to
talk about some that's important
so another thing about it is that
strikes me as particularly silly i've
written a book about this
is if you read the dictionaries of
independence you will find that it comes
in three parts
and in the first part it states some
universal principles very beautiful
and in the second part it contains a
bill of particulars in 17 paragraphs
about
bad stuff the king of england did which
bad stuff
justifies the making of america throwing
off the old government and
adopting a new one and those things are
remarkably like the constitution united
states what did the king do wrong
well he interfered with the legislature
which is a violation of the first step
in all government the making of laws but
also a violation of separation of powers
which is crucial to how the constitution
united states worked
so separation of powers is important and
then
he interfered with the people's ability
to
elect legislators in other words
representation
a key feature of the constitution of the
united states
and then he interfered with the judges
he would ship people
arrest them for crimes and ship them off
to england where they couldn't be tried
by a jury of their peers
nor before judges who are independent of
the executive branch which more or less
the king was
so you see they're writing the
constitution right there
if you have a government that does these
things
then you are justified to rebel against
that government
and to kill anybody who resists you
so it implies the constitution
now what kind of thing that they are
different to that critical independence
and the constitution they serve
different functions
they also sound different in a very
interesting way
the declaration independence is really
beautiful um
you know when in the course of human
events it becomes necessary for one
people to
dissolve the political bands that have
connected them with another
and to assume among the powers of the
earth to separate an equal station
which the laws of nature and nature's
god entitle them isn't that a grand
expression the laws of nature and of
nature's god
it's written like that also it's not
time bound when in the course of human
events
that means any time in the course of
human events it becomes necessary for
one people that means any people
anywhere anytime the claim is
what's going to follow in this document
is right
at all times and so one way to think
about the difference between the
dichroism and the constitution is
it's a document about ultimate purposes
what they call in classic philosophy
final causes
vital causes are the things that we seek
above all others the things we would die
for
uh and so the next independence states
those and of course those words echo
around the world still today even when
they're distorted you're going to learn
something about that in this course
well the constitution is not quite like
that uh
the constitution is uh it provides a
form of government and when you read it
you know i've regarded it as beautiful
and think i understand why it's
beautiful
it has to do with its structure which
madison says is the most important thing
about it
but you know on any given passage
right um it's full of details
like there's a list in article 1 section
8 things the congress can do
well post offices and post roads is
among them
it's hard to write a beautiful sentence
about that
no this is a document about how the
government is going to work
even how it's going to look
it looks like a thing that operates in
three branches
if the if if there's a interviews going
on in front of the white house which
there are every day on the nightly news
there's a picture of the white house in
the background because that's where the
president works and that's where
executive things are done
and if there's a if there's something
big in the congress then there's
uh cameras looking up at the capitol
dome because that's where the congress
operates and where the legislation is
made and the same for the supreme court
building
in operation the government
looks like the constitution and sure
enough the first three articles in the
constitution
one of them the first one sets up the
legislative branch
beginning with the words all legislative
power herein granted
and one thing you're going to learn in
this course is that we don't make our
laws through the congress
anymore that's why there can be so many
of them
and that's why it's impossible to hold
to account
those who make them except very
indirectly indeed it's even hard to find
out who makes them
i think there are 150 law making
agencies in the federal government now
so each of those clauses
establish one two three the way the
government of the united states
looks uh and so
if you think about it you couldn't have
any serious
activity that did not have a final cause
a whole bunch of people cooperating
sometimes at risk to their lives
suffering and trouble and sacrifice
that started right at the beginning
because the first thing that happened
after the detroit's independence was we
well actually it already happened a bit
before
we're having a war with england the
greatest power on earth
and to undertake that you need a big
reason you need some
ultimate reason and anytime people think
of their deaths
they always think of what they live
their lives for
that's what the declaration of
independence is but then on the other
hand
if you're actually going to have a great
government
then there's going to have to be ways
for it to operate because think what it
has to achieve
it has to grant power the doctrine of
the doctor's independence is that all
legitimate power stems from those who
are governed
no other source but then somehow
you've got to get some way to get
legitimacy
into the things that the government does
and have that
operate on a routine basis so if you're
going to have a
legitimate government you're going to
have to have a form a recognized way by
which it operates
and so the constitution provides that
one you could say is the final cause and
the other is the formal cost
now i'm going to back up a step and ask
a question that's prevalent today and
that is
why should you have any government at
all what do you need it for
and then we were just over in england uh
as we're making this course and we were
celebrating the completion of the
official biography of winston churchill
and there was a couple of young
english guys who are working and helping
us get around
and they were delightful people and i
got into long talks with them and they
just made the point
because you know they're having the big
debate about whether they separate from
the european union over there or not and
young as a rule don't favor the
separation and they said well we're not
english we're european
and i said what if you don't like
something the european
union does oh there's a lot we don't
like we want to see it reformed
and i said good what means do you have
to achieve that reform
because it's kind of difficult isn't it
it's 29 countries i think aren't they
they don't all speak the same language
how would you have a conversation with a
wide body of fellow citizens
to establish a thing like major reforms
to the government
and that's a point isn't it because in
the constitution
well in the place in the federalist
papers which are assigned to read along
with this course and i
urge you to read them and reread them
because they're a great achievement in
political thought one of the greatest
and one of the greatest
american such achievements
and in the 51st federalist madison
explaining why you have to build a
constitution
that uh that has precautions in it
it has to grant power you have to have
that
but also it has to constrain
power you have to have that and the way
he puts the point
is uh what is government but the
profoundest of all reflections on human
nature
if men were angels no government would
be necessary
if angels were to govern men neither
internal or external
controls on the government would be
needed
see what that means he's locating us
in the hierarchy of nature down at the
bottom of the beast
of the rocks and up at the top are
angels
and god and if angels were being
being governed although there's a record
in the bible that their behavior is not
perfect
uh still it's true that is a common run
it's probably a lot better than ours and
they don't
they're imagined as as a disembodied
intellect
and so they don't have all the needs and
pressures we have
and the beast they just always obey
instinct
whereas we're moral beings
which means we're called to do right and
we don't always
and that is actually the reason why we
need laws
but madison just makes the common sense
points the people who make the laws
are people too how do we know they won't
make them in their own
interest well you need a constitution
and it needs to be in control of the
governed
and so the reason nations and that word
nation it comes from the latin word
natura which means nature
and that means that uh the making of
laws
is written in human nature and it
actually precedes
aristotle says from our ability to talk
because the that's a pregnant thing
about us that's the big thing about us
and so this uh need for government
is fundamental and on the other hand
we need to be able to control it and
nations therefore are conceived as
natural things
where people can understand each other
they say
they share a common final cause as in
the declaration of independence
which tells us what our nation is for
and then they can cooperate with each
other
to appoint and manage a government that
responds to their will
so it's actually true then isn't it that
in this age where
we're asking nationalism for
internationalism
the dexterous independence uh
talks about that and mark the point i've
already made it
the doctor's independence begins
universally
it says that everybody has rights
every human being the same in every age
no matter where
and then it says that to secure
these rights governments are instituted
among men
deriving their just powers from the
consent of the governed
in other words this universal rights
that we have
they call for government to protect
those rights
and they call for a kind of government
that will be responsive to us
it's a remarkable thing i think
it's hard to quarrel with the assertion
which i make all the time
that the greatest of the modern
countries is the united states of
america
well its story is tremendous right
because
it begins with a new world nobody knew
where it was nobody knew what it was
uh until about 1806 i think it was
nobody really knew how big it was
nobody gone across the new world and all
the way back
until about then lewis and clark
so something happened on this new land
and what was it they picked up a
civilization
it's like in the western movies you know
they're often a contest between somebody
who's got a law book and somebody who's
got a gun
and in the towns where the westerns take
place there's no capacity at all to
produce
either a law book or a gun but they know
about them because they've come
from a well-developed civilization and
brought it out to the frontier
that's what the whole western movies are
just recreations of american history
because the civilization mostly of
europe
with its understanding of god and its
understanding of right
and its learning and its understanding
of nature
that comes over here and those people
brought all that in their minds
and hearts what they didn't bring
was aristocracy they didn't bring
an established elite to run everything
what they brought instead was ideas
of freedom and equality and so there was
this new world
and a bunch of people got to take it
over and they had because you know
the first settlements are about 150
years
before the declaration of independence
and that 150 years was a time of great
learning
uh one of the most remarkable things
that was learned
was that most of the early settlers came
because of religious persecution
and they thought the solution to that
was to set up communities
where their religion was installed by
law
and protected and everybody had to
practice it
and they thought it's a big old country
if somebody
doesn't like it they can go somewhere
else so religious conformity was
more or less the rule early on though
the idea
came to be we don't really have to fight
about that
because first of all we do fight a lot
about it uh
they were they used to in massachusetts
bay colony
they used to hang quakers for coming to
town to try to convert people to
quakerism
and quakers are christians you know
different brand
and so they thought that through
and in the course of that 150 years they
adopted the idea
of civil and religious freedom and
that's in the declaration of
independence right because
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
that has to do including with our duty
to god
and so that religion should be
respected but also free
that's born that's reaches its
perfection
in the declaration of independence god i
should say
uh occurs four times in the declaration
of independence
and it's an interesting thing because it
uh it
demonstrates the way they talk of him
how important god is
and it demonstrates also how important
limited government is
because god appears first as the maker
of the laws of nature
nature's god the legislator then he
appears
as the supreme judge of the world
the judge and then he appears as
divine providence the executive branch
and then he appears up higher up in as
the creator the founder
of all things right and the lesson of
the choice of independence is one god is
a standard greatly to be respected
and worshiped and understood
but two you wouldn't combine all those
powers
in the hand of any any being except god
not for men so you see
this uh tremendous opportunity which
i i can't see myself how it would ever
be repeated in history
because there isn't a new world anymore
maybe space
um but uh
there's nowhere to go like that anymore
and so they went there and they got 150
years to work on it
and then they proclaimed a regime
defined by these two documents
that's one of the most important events
in human history in my opinion
say a thing or two about the
constitution because that's important
um first of all i mentioned that it's
divided into groups and there are seven
articles in the constitution united
states and the first three set up the
three branches of government
but then a second thing about it's
interesting and that is that
it's not an unlimited government
there's something called the police
power which comes from english common
law very old
and it's the general authority to
legislate for the health safety and
welfare of the people
state governments in america have that
and that means that if the state if a
state government
tries to do something you know there are
provisions in state constitutions and in
the federal
constitution that forbid them to do many
things but the presumption is
they have the power to do it if it fits
within that common law
definition which is very wide whereas
the constitution the united states
delegates certain powers to the federal
government
and just think what a different thing in
kind that is
like hillsdale college has articles of
incorporation
and they're very beautiful by the way
and we follow them here closely
but when it comes to the operation of
the colleges it basically grants us the
board and me and
the staff here power to do anything a
college needs to do
well the federal government's not like
that the federal government has
article 1 section 8 and uh and that's a
limit
on the government you see
the the clauses are it's not hard to
state what they're about
is about national defense the big job of
the federal government
the second biggest group is provisions
to guarantee a system of national
commerce
all over the nation one nation as
regards
economics contracts are to be respected
um uh bankruptcies there should be a
provision
for them so that
you have to be a legal process before
you can get out of your debts but there
should be such a process
money weights and measures
it's going to be a great nation trading
freely
inside its borders and that will make
the nation
strong and nations need to be strong
in order to defend themselves and the
only other things that are powers given
to the federal government are basically
to
operate in the states on the ground
where the federal government has
installations
so the post office is federal territory
and the federal building they're way too
many of those now but uh
there's a provision for them right from
the beginning so it's a
limited government and whatever it does
it has to justify by a specific
provision in the constitution
that permits it and that's not the
strictest rule in the world
you know there's leeway
but but it's a different kind of thing
than to begin on the basis you can do
whatever you please
the last thing i'll say about the
constitution is uh
what's it trying to do um
we we like to say today if we're
conservative-minded people which i
happen to be
that uh the constitution is to limit the
government
but of course that's obviously not true
the first thing it does is empower the
government
and it's uh it's uh all over the
constitution and the documents
surrounding it
that everybody understood they need a
strong government in fact the
constitution itself which replaced the
articles of confederation
was written in part because the articles
were failing
and the reason they were failing was the
government wasn't strong enough to
protect our rights
there were foreign troops on our soil
and we couldn't do anything about it
couldn't pay our debts there were riots
in the states and they couldn't be put
down
madison writes all this up in a really
great essay before the constitutional
convention
called vices of the political system of
the united states it's in our
constitution reader
and so they need a stronger government
but they divide it now what is the
purpose of the
division and you have to think about how
profound the division is although it's
been much
overcome by the growth of the
administrative state and the bureaucracy
which you're going to hear a lot about
in this course
it's still true that it's a it's a
tremendous
achievement because in dividing the
powers
they arranged for different methods of
election
of the different parts so the president
serves for four years
uh the house representative serves for
two
the senate serves for six the judges are
appointed by the president
on advice of the senate
the constituencies are different
the constituency for a senator is a
state
the constituency for the president is an
electoral college made up
of the which you win by majority that's
under pressure these days
which you win by majority uh of
the electors in in the states and the
electors are calculated according to the
number of senators and representatives
each state has so you see
what it does it spreads
authority across space and you remember
this is the greatest and most extensive
republic in human history
and they were trying to unite a
continent the full size of which they
did not quite know yet
although george washington did name his
army the continental army
so they wanted spread and so the senate
spreads
political authority and that means
people who live in the very different
and widely separated parts of the
country
all get a say even if they're not very
numerous
and then on the other hand it spreads
authority across
time because if you want to change
something in the american government
the fastest you can possibly turn the
whole government over
is six years because it takes three
elections
to elect a whole senate and the
president two-thirds of that amount of
time
so that means that uh it places a
premium
on opinions that we hold firmly
and for a long time and madison makes
this point
beautifully in the federalist papers and
more than once
uh in the 49th i think it is he says
it is our reason alone that must be
placed in control of the government
our passions must be controlled by it so
we're supposed to think
before we act here's another feature of
the constitution
in the 63rd federalist madison says that
this is the first
purely representative government in
history he's claiming a uniqueness
and what does he mean by purely
representative he means that
the sovereign sovereign in england was
the king and he was the executive branch
the song sovereign in athens was the
free citizens and they were the
legislative branch
the sovereignty the sovereign in america
is the constitutional majority
but they don't occupy a branch of
government
we don't control i mean they've
introduced the referendum
things like that in later years but
there's no federal
referendum process why madison thought
it would be good for us
because you know just like you can't
trust the government fully because
they're people
you can't trust us fully either because
we're people too
and so we can only act
through elections that makes
elections important in america and it
also means
we can't do anything by the spur of the
moment
the best decision is not being made on
the spur of the moment
and i'll state a telling exception to
that too
the president is specifically empowered
to
act alone and that's in matters of
execution think of the different
meanings of that term
execution when you've got a war
you have to act suddenly but
laws prevail because of course
if the president starts a war and the
congress doesn't like it or if he sends
a bunch of troops somewhere
they don't have to supply any money for
that and the money will run
out if they will put a stop to it and
they have often in american history and
threatened other times
so you see the idea is that
we have all the power but we can't
act except through our representatives
and that adds
patience and and deliberation to the
process
and then a last thing the size of the
of the united states the fact that it's
spread so far
the fact that it includes so many people
in so many jurisdictions you know the
states are supposed to have a lot more
authority than they have these days and
one of my wishes is to see it restored
a lot of other things like that too but
when it's spread all over the place
let's say
uh you've got 10 little conspiratorial
friends
you know you can if you got 10 little
conspiratorial friends you can
meet in dark rooms and whisper to each
other nobody need find out
but what's 10 going to do in a country
this size
in fact to influence the country you
have to cr you have to talk
across millions of people hundreds of
thousands in the
founding millions now tens of millions
now
and you have to you have to speak across
vast
spaces and madison writes
that will teach us to be more candid
with each other
we you know we we love to say that
uh all politicians are liars and i think
that's not quite true
but it's a rough truth but on the other
hand think how much worse it would be
if they didn't have to talk in front of
us and if they weren't free to
contradict each other
and i i want to close with this point
because it's fundamentally important
there are just two ways of governing
human beings
and one is by talking and the others by
force
because we are the speaking beings
this rationality that we have that lets
us use common nouns
that's what makes us political and so
legitimate political
systems are always built on talking
not on violence they may take violence
to install
they may require violence to persist
and to defend but they must not proceed
in their ordinary workings by violence
of one citizen upon another
and so we we have a political system
that first of all is meant
to protect our rights which are written
in our nature the decisive part of which
is our ability to reason
and and talk
but also we have a nation where we're
supposed to discuss
things and teach each other and learn
from each other
and i'll go back to the european union
the polls and the checks and the english
and the french don't really have a good
way to talk to each other
except through the agencies of the
european union
and that means it's very difficult for
there to be a culture
in which public opinion is formed freely
among all of the people who are affected
they can't speak with each other
routinely there's translation programs
and lots of people speak more than one
language in europe
and yet to talk in your native tongue
the tongue in which you've been educated
and by which you
articulate your best thoughts that's
what you do especially with fellow
citizens
it's become a very great country in the
course of its history
beyond the imaginings even of the people
who founded it who were
extremely ambitious people they had the
highest
possible hopes all right well if that's
true
there must have been some cause of it
but also it's in that final purpose
we serve that we have adopted it's a
purpose available to all human beings
we have adopted it for our own
and then finally in this form of
government we have
under the constitution which is itself a
reflection of human nature
and that is why it has worked so well
so i'll close with the editorial point
well known
i think we ought to restore the
authority of the constitution
and the declaration of independence
thank you
[Music]